Teleportation, we see it all the time in
the movies. I start here
and end up here, crossing no physical
space and in no time at all. But where
are we with actual teleportation? Well
it turns out we're already doing it in
the quantum world. Thankfully I have a
scientist who's ready to explain it to
me in the time it takes for an elevator
to go up a very tall building. All right
beam me up.
Oh Andrea. Hi! So you taught me about
quantum entanglement before? Yes.
And today you're going to teach me about
quantum teleportation right? Is it any
easier? It's not easier but it's useful so there's that. Let's do it. What is
quantum teleportation? It's a way to
transmit bits of information at a
distance in a way that is unhackable and
the reason it's secure is because it
uses pairs of entangled particles.
For example, photons where the zero
is a horizontal polarization and one is
a vertical polarization.
Photons are created entangled in
opposite polarization but you don't know
which one it is, they're just the
opposite. Now imagine on my computer I have one bit of information and I want
to send you that bit. Now the photons get separated and sent to computer number
one and computer number two. Yeah. When
the photon arrives and I measure it
together with my bit, if let's say they
become the same
that means this photon is a one, your
photon has become a zero because it's
created opposite to the one I've got.
Right now at this point, you haven't
learned anything yet you just got a zero
as a random number but then I can take
the phone and call you and say, "hey
my two are the same"
and because of that I'll know what bit I
wanted to send you. Because you have a
zero, at the other end this must be a one
and if I tell you my bit is the same
then you know I have a one so now you've
learned a bit of information I wanted to
send you. You're teleporting the
information. Right. Now imagine someone is
eavesdropping our phone call. All they're
getting is "same" or "opposite" which is
completely random. They're not learning
anything. There's no way to hack it. It's
been used for example in Switzerland 15
years ago in the local elections
and the vote was transmitted using this
quantum teleportation method to the
central voting shared station. So weird.
It's not weird. It is
not weird. Quantum is not weird.
That's just the way it
works. You have particles that are
created opposite by some natural
processes and then you just use that
property of them being
opposite to each other but not having a
state of their own to do these clever
tricks to transmit information that
cannot be hacked. You know what I do
think that this one was easier because
it's useful right when I can think of it
in like real terms that makes it so much
easier. Nice. That was sick, thanks.
Pleasure.
So quantum teleportation is a little bit
complicated so let me get settled in and
get this right. So quantum teleportation
it's a way of transferring information
that is mostly unhackable theoretically
if you get every part right. So it uses
quantum entanglement which as I learned
earlier is when you have two quantum
entangled particles that are always
going to be opposite of each other. With
polarity one's going to be horizontal,
one's going to be vertical and even if
you pull them apart from each other
they're going to remain opposite from
each other. So say I have a message I'm
at point a and I want to send something
to point b. I first translate my
information into something that can
correlate with these polarities, say bits,
zeros and ones, binary. We use it all the
time in computers and then I send two
quantum entangled particles from my to
myself and then to location B and
they're going to be opposites of each
other. So when I look at my information
that I want to send in relation to the
quantum entangled particle I can see if
it's for example the same or different. Did it come out as horizontal or
vertical? In relation to my bits and then
when I know all that I can talk to
location B and say, "hey this one was the
same, this one was different, this was the
same" and they can work backwards from
that to figure out what information I
was sending because they have my
entangled quantum particle and this is
unhackable because if someone else was
to intercept a photon or a quantum
particle I simply wouldn't get it. They
would know that it wasn't there and that
by itself doesn't mean anything. It's
only when it's correlated with the other
information that it starts to make sense.
Cool but also quantum is weird.
It was a bit messy but it was it was
correct... But it gave the sense of
suffering
[Laughter]
Hey, thanks for watching  If your brain is
feeling a little bit like mush after all
of those quantum mechanics don't worry
you're not alone. But if you want to make
it feel even more like mush check out
the other video that I did with Andrea
and remember to subscribe to ABC Science for more videos.